der fall von dem wir ihnen jetzt
erzählen der könnte nach 29 jahren
tatsächlich aufgeklärt werden 1992
verschwand diese junge frau hier die
sieger spurlos und jetzt am wochenende
da kam nach einem hinweis deutschlands
einziger knochen spüren zum einsatz
finster und finster und der hat hier an
der bundesstraße 13 zwischen ansbach und
nürnberg gesucht und dann tatsächlich
hier an einer brücke angeschlagen
genauer an einem brückenpfeiler und an
diesem fehler da ist auch das baujahr
eingraviert und zwar das jahr 1992 also
genau das jahr in dem auch wieder
verschwunden ist sascha baumann und jörg
völkerling berichten
bringt knochen spürhund flintstones den
durchbruch in einem seit 29 jahren
ungelösten kriminalfall der vierbeiner
riecht sterbliche überreste durch wände
und erdschichten und jetzt hat er
angeschlagen
[Musik]
also die aufgabe von fenstern heute ist
möglichst ein skelett zu finden einer
vermissten frau die erste schwierige
aufgabe was wir uns für heute vormittag
vorgenommen haben ist das absuchen
das land ist einer einer bundesstraße
seit sommer 1992 ist die franken
lieselotte lauer verschwunden jetzt die
wende im cold case knochen spürhund
flintstones schlägt an an einer brücke
unweit ihres damaligen wohnorts gebaut
im jahr 1992
der schreckliche verdacht wurde
lieselotte ermordet und ihre leiche in
dieser brücke einbetoniert
[Musik]
am ersten juli nur 92 kurz nach
mitternacht kommt lieselotte lauer von
der spätschicht im gunzenhäuser sel werk
nach hause hier nach hahndorf am
mühlacker 2 die nachbarin hört sie nur
kurz ihre dachgeschosswohnung betreten
möglicherweise versorgt sie schnell ihre
katze doch schon nach wenigen minuten
verlässt sie das haus wieder und ist
dann acht stunden unterwegs mit wem wo
weiß man bis heute nicht
um acht uhr morgens konnte sie nach
hause doch nur zwei stunden später
verlässt die damals 30 jährige ihre
wohnung erneut und fährt ins acht
kilometer entfernte gunzenhausen
eine zeugin sieht lizzy um 10 uhr 30 am
marktplatz sie ist die letzte person die
liselotte lauer sehen wird lissy
verschwindet danach spurlos
kurz vor ihrem verschwinden trennt sich
von ihrem freund mit dem sie acht jahre
zusammen war zieht in eine neue wohnung
der beginn eines neuen lebens
mysteriös ihr ex freund berichtet nach
ihrer trennung von wiederholten anrufen
eines unbekannten dort meldete sich eine
männliche stimme ein mann der offenbar
das haus von lissy lauer beobachtet
hatte und warnte den freund er sollte
sich ihr nicht nähern sie sei dort
gerade hineingegangen mit ihrem neuen
freund
wer wallis neuer freund und wer war der
mysteriöse anrufer was weiß er überließ
verschwinden oder war er ihr mörder
durch hinweise aus der bevölkerung
nehmen die ermittler den fall lieselotte
lauer erneut auf mit flynn stone gehen
sie den hinweisen nach suchen mit ihm
die b13 ab mehrmals bildwerk noch ein
spürhund an der brücke zu der ihn die
polizeibeamten führen
durch finster uns einsatz scheint die
lösung des cold case nach fast 30 jahren
und die verurteilung von lucies mörder
denn mord verjährt nie
wir haben es gehört seit dem 1
1792 wird die damals 30-jährige
lieselotte lauer vermisst die kripo und
die staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt seit
mai
2021 in einem sogenannten cold case fall
und gehen von einem tötungsdelikt aus
für entscheidende hinweise die zu einer
festnahme des täters führen ist eine
belohnung von 10.000 euro ausgesetzt
wenn sie solche hinweise haben dann
wenden sie sich an die kripo ansbach
unter 0 800 7 7 6 6 3 2 0